[Music]
on this friday night troublesome
trajectory we may be experiencing a bit
of turbulence the cases of kova 19 on
the rise in canada and the timeline for
getting kids vaccinated britain sends
military reinforcements to poland over
the migrant crisis the situation at the
border is desperate and it's getting
worse by the day
from police officer to prisoner the case
of a canadian constable that has led to
a review of policing in newfoundland and
labrador
and canada's soccer goals the excitement
kicking up over the world cup qualifier
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us just when canada was making strides
with vaccinations the number of coveted
19 cases is back on the rise ontario is
reporting the highest jump with just
under 600 new cases that province has
seen a steady increase in the past two
weeks so far hospitalizations are
staying steady in ontario but in
manitoba it's a more worrying picture in
the last week kofi 19 hospital
admissions were up 23
and the number of icu patients has
increased by 25
they mostly involve unvaccinated people
and today the vaccine drive got another
boost health canada has approved
modernist application for a booster shot
as abigail beeman reports in our top
story tonight there is also promising
news for parents
it looks like we may be experiencing a
bit of turbulence this week case counts
up by 11 percent the country's top
doctor points to cooler weather bringing
people indoors plus loosening
restrictions covered 19 particles
disperse much faster when we let fresh
air into the room on airborne
transmission teresa tam seems to be
following the uk's lead they released
this video encouraging people to open
the window even briefly when gathering
for the holidays we've learned how the
virus can linger in fine aerosols and
remain suspended in the air we breathe
much as expel smoke lingers the
scientific data is now really quite
clear that there is airborne
transmission or aerosol transmission of
copit19 what's open to debate is what
proportion of transmission is due to
that route many parents are frustrated
american kids have been getting
vaccinated for two weeks while pfizer's
pediatric vaccine hasn't been approved
by health canada the review is actively
ongoing and we expect to have a final
decision in the next one to two weeks
pfizer gave data to the fda before
health canada let's be happy they're not
rushing it they only got this data last
month mid last month so they are moving
at a good space they're pretty brisk and
in the meantime experts recommend
layering protections why for heaven's
sake can't people wear their masks and
why need people use a coke or a popcorn
as an excuse not to add a mask i simply
am at a loss new modeling from ontario's
covet 19 science advisory table shows
cases are rising they project icu
occupancy to increase though
hospitalizations are currently stable
concluding the province's reopening
pause on high risk settings like
nightclubs was wise if you see
acceleration don't step on the gas pedal
another outstanding question the
requirement for a negative cova test to
enter canada friday the conservatives
called to match the u.s drop the pcr
requirement for land entry and give an
option for a rapid antigen test if
entering by air for the second week in a
row dr tam would only say those
requirements are under review robin
abigail beeman in ottawa thanks abigail
europe is once again the global
epicenter of the pandemic reporting the
highest number of new cases and deaths
since april 2020 when the virus first
swept through italy the continent now
accounts for more than half of the
weekly infections worldwide in the last
seven days that number was more than 2
million and in the last week europe
reported more than half the global
deaths with more than 28 000
that has prompted some european
governments to impose partial lockdowns
including the netherlands starting
saturday for three weeks bars and
restaurants will close early and
sporting events will be held without
spectators residents won't be allowed to
invite more than four guests into their
homes and social distancing rules will
be reinstated the lockdown measures are
the first in western europe since the
summer new infections topped 16 000 for
a second day in a row in the netherlands
despite 85 percent of adults being fully
vaccinated
and in a rare move austria is set to
place millions of unvaccinated people in
lockdown the restrictions will affect
the two hardest hit regions of upper
austria and saltsburg so starting monday
people in those areas can only leave
home for work and to shop for essentials
the government says it's still
considering a nationwide lockdown for
unvaccinated people about 65 percent of
the population is fully vaccinated one
of the lowest rates in western europe
turning to the migrant crisis in europe
britain is now sending in troops to help
poland as tensions escalate on the
border with belarus the polish
government is caught in the middle of a
battle between belarus and the rest of
the european union the president of
belarus is being accused of encouraging
illegal border crossings to retaliate
against eu sanctions as mike delay
reports the political posturing has
created a dangerous stalemate
it's getting cold on the border between
belarus and poland you can read it on
the foreheads of migrant children the
only thing heating up right now is the
political tension
russia announced it was conducting
military exercises with belarus leaving
poland to increase its military presence
now the united kingdom has stepped in
sending a team of soldiers to help
poland strengthen its borders
belarus's defense minister has warned
poland not to overestimate its abilities
i want to warn all the hotheads he said
bella russian armed forces are ready to
fight back harshly on anything
one can hope that it's posturing that it
won't escalate the problem is that when
you have a proximity
of military forces
there can be miscalculations
so there is no evidence that there is an
intent to escalate this by
uh russia
or nato
but there is a risk of escalation
that is inadvertent meanwhile migrants
who believed this was the gateway to a
new life in europe remains stuck behind
barbed wire the european union has
accused belarus of manufacturing the
crisis in retaliation for sanctions
imposed on minsk over human rights
abuses we increasingly hear rhetoric
coming out of brussels like hybrid war
this is not war these are not weapons
these are people and they deserve to be
treated like people with dignity respect
and care
at least for now one key route into
belarus has been shut down turkish
airlines one of the main international
airlines flying into minsk has agreed to
suspend the sale of one-way tickets to
people in syria yemen and iraq
people are being sold a lie
by smugglers and with no country willing
to take in any more refugees that lie
has left eastern europe with
humanitarian crisis
wrapped in a political stalemate mike
draleigh global news toronto
canada's new foreign affairs minister
met with her u.s counterpart today her
first stateside visit since being
appointed last month melanie jolie says
she pressed u.s secretary of state
anthony blinken on two key issues ahead
of next week's so-called three amigos
summit with canada the u.s and mexico
canada is concerned about president
biden's proposed u.s tax credit for
american-built electric vehicles ottawa
says it would hurt the integrated auto
industry and put thousands of jobs at
risk
canadians know that we have to defend
our interests and we can't never take
anything for granted so that's my job to
defend canadians interests while making
sure that we have a very strong
friendship relationship with the us
julie says they also talked about the
enbridge line 5 pipeline which is before
the courts the state of michigan is
pushing to close it on environmental
grounds well the deadline has come and
gone at the cop 26 climate summit and
negotiators are still trying to hammer
out a global accord the draft agreement
calls for a doubling of funds to help
poor countries deal with the effects of
climate change but consensus is still
needed on the future of fossil fuels and
emissions targets crystal command sing
reports from glasgow on the sticking
points 1.5
is non-negotiable our safety the safety
of my children
and yours
hangs in the balance debating the final
details in glasgow delegates ran out the
clock we are struggling
each year to find money
but 2.5 trillion dollars
in the last five years six years went
into subsidies for fossil fuel that's a
definition of insanity
u.s climate envoy john kerry was
unequivocal saying all countries must
end fossil fuel subsidies and phase out
coal for the first time in cop history
the draft agreement released wednesday
included such language but as feared it
was watered down
[Applause]
[Music]
frustrated climate activists held a red
line demonstration walking out along
with some delegates the people in there
failed us as expected and i think people
just want to show their anger i've been
at this climate fight for a long time
canada's environment minister says the
country already has pledges on the books
to end fossil fuel subsidies by 2023
we have our work cut out for us to make
our commitments a reality
but we are demonstrating a path
a way it can be done
by a country that is both a big energy
producer and consumer
and home to some of the world's largest
remaining intact nature
another sticking point how much money
richer countries will give to developing
ones to build up green technologies and
cover the cost of damage as a result of
climate change
the philippines which has seen the
effects of a warming planet noted that
developing nations can't repeat the same
mistakes of the industrial revolution
greenhouse gas emissions must be cut the
planet has already warmed too much i
think there's a lot of people already
suffering now but the whole of humanity
will be suffering dearly if we don't
change our behavior putting those
changes into writing is proving
difficult negotiations are expected to
continue into saturday while the young
face of the climate movement is back at
her post demanding action now
crystal gomez in global news london
the growing civil unrest in haiti has
forced canada to pull out non-essential
staff and their family members from the
embassy in puerto prance global affairs
canada says the embassy will stay open
to help canadians still there ottawa has
already urged canadian citizens to leave
the country if they can safely gang
violence and kidnappings have been
escalating in this small caribbean
country since last month when gangs
sealed off the port where fuel is stored
in newfoundland and labrador a judge has
sentenced a police officer to four years
in prison constable doug snelgrove was
on duty and in uniform when he picked up
a woman in his car and then sexually
assaulted her at her home he's a member
of the royal newfoundland constabulary
now other women are coming forward to
complain about officers in the same
department accusing them of sexual
misconduct here's ross lord the
sentencing judge called constable doug
snow girl's actions reprehensible while
on duty snow grove offered a woman a
drive home in his patrol car at 3 a.m
then sexually assaulted her when they
got there
and handing down a four year prison term
the judge suggested the case is
extremely rare the prosecutor agrees i
couldn't locate any similar case when
officer committed sexual assault while
in uniform the woman had spent the
evening in the popular downtown district
near saint john's she told the court she
awoke to find snell grove raping her she
said she suffered mental anguish and
depression ever since her ordeal was
made even worse by legal errors that led
to three trials before snellgrove was
finally convicted seven years after he
raped her but there's a larger even more
disturbing question
is snell grove just one sexual abuser in
a wider pattern of abuse at first the
police department suggested otherwise
the rnc
came out and really had messaging about
the fact that this is about a couple of
bad apples and we're really not
addressing the fact that what they've
got is a
issue with institutional culture and
misogyny within that culture in fact 13
other women have made allegations about
multiple different constabulary officers
committing sexual offenses against them
and it's very telling they have not come
forward to the police but have come
forward to lawyer lynn moore and what
we're seeing um you know obviously is
that broken trust
trusts it won't be restored by one
prison sentence criminologists say a
six-month independent review of the rnc
ordered last month by the provincial
government is crucial it's a matter of
assessing also what is the current
culture how has it changed or not
changed and then how can we continue to
start making changes moving forward that
are going to be useful
the judge said the snellgrow sentence
should send a message to others in
positions of authority the courts will
deal appropriately with this type of
conduct i'm satisfied the judge
considered all the factors and pro and
impose a sentence that is a deterrent
snellgrove has been suspended without
pay for six years until the appeal
process is exhausted he is still a
member of the rnc
ross lord global news
halifax
independence day for britney spears
are you guys
coming up the decision on the
conservatorship that's controlled the
pop star's life plus former trump
adviser steve bannon is in legal trouble
[Applause]
the free britney movement was on hand
for a termination rally outside an l.a
courthouse this afternoon where a judge
granted the pop star for freedom
the judge ended a conservatorship that
held control over the pop star's life
and money for nearly 14 years speer's
father started the arrangement citing
his daughter's mental health and
struggles with substance abuse but in
recent years the 39 year old called the
arrangement abusive and exploitive
spears credits the free brittany
movement for ending the conservatorship
now that it's dissolved there's a plan
in place to help spears transition to
life on her own
we have breaking news from washington
steve bannon has been indicted for
contempt of congress bannon was once the
chief strategist to president donald
trump he failed to comply with a
subpoena for documents and testimony as
part of the investigation into the
january 6 siege at the u.s capitol
building bannon is expected to turn
himself in on monday the indictment
could signal trouble for other trump
advisers who've also refused to
cooperate with the investigation
up next the indigenous guardians and
their fight against climate change
you're watching global national
some important pledges have been made at
comp 26 but on the front lines of
climate change pledges are just words
there is a group in canada though taking
action combining modern science and
ancestral knowledge to protect nature
they're called indigenous guardians
donna friesen got extraordinary access
to see their work on the coast of
british columbia
stunning and rich with life the heltzig
people have lived here for thousands of
years sustained by the bounty of the
land in the sea and living in harmony
with it
there were
many many
villages
throughout our whole territory and
almost every river system
in our territory
was utilized by our people here
indigenous guardians are monitoring the
salmon run walking where their ancestors
did they are the eyes and the ears on
the front lines of climate change and
they say it's time the world listened so
we have guardian watchmen that will come
into every salmon system
bearing stream that we have
and see whether or not there's salmon
running in their systems to
inform
whether or not we're
comfortable with opening up a commercial
fishery or even a food fishery for
people and it's helping rebuild
connections broken by colonialism and
residential schools
we did stand on the abyss
of near extinction and an annihilation
we are a resilient people
you'll hear some powerful voices talking
about the value of indigenous
traditional knowledge and what we can
all learn from it in our special report
for the new reality
all right thanks donna still ahead a
canadian soccer star's homecoming sets
the stage for a world cup qualifier
in men's soccer canada is emerging as
the team to beat our national men's team
is halfway to qualifying for the world
cup and the players are on a roll
they've been undefeated in their first
six matches and tonight at commonwealth
stadium in edmonton they take on costa
rica for the first time as morgan black
explains it'll be a special homecoming
for one of canada's biggest soccer stars
robin he's played all over the world but
tonight for the first time in his career
superstar alfonso davies is representing
canada in his home town in front of fans
family and friends it's expected there's
going to be 45 000 people at
commonwealth stadium tonight the stadium
has not seen a crowd of this size in
quite some time tonight's match against
costa rica is one of two crucial world
cup qualifying games being played here
in edmonton after tonight the men's team
is back tuesday against mexico canada
will be looking to capitalize on home
field advantage and soccer fans here
can't wait to watch it all go down
we've seen a lot of excitement with team
canada in town and i've seen quite a few
people walking around downtown edmonton
decked out in their team canada red and
white alfonzo davies is also excited to
be at home he has been all smiles on the
field during practice this week the 21
year old's parents will be in the crowd
they haven't watched him play a game
since he was a teenager now we're known
for our love of hockey here but soccer
has become increasingly popular and in
part that's because of davey's star
power he grew up in edmonton after
coming to canada as a refugee and his
impact on the community here has been
immense we stopped by a local soccer
academy that trains some of the best
young players in edmonton davies still
visits their program regularly he
inspires me a lot i'll watch one of his
sprints or something and will make me
want to go maybe commonwealth
wherever just to try that we're hoping
to inspire them we're hoping to inspire
you know generations not the generation
of young footballers in edmonton and
across canada as well the canadian men's
soccer team hasn't qualified for a world
cup since 1986 right now they sit third
in their group the top three teams
automatically advanced to qatar in 2022
a pair of wins tonight and on tuesday
would put canada in a great position
weather-wise players and fans have
struck it lucky for a november night in
edmonton the temperature is expected to
hover around zero coven 19 protocols are
in place at the stadium fans will have
to show either proof of vaccine or a
negative covet 19 test to get in and
with 45 000 people attending fans are
encouraged to get here early robin all
right morgan block in edmonton thanks
morgan and that is global national for
this friday i'm robin gill tonight your
canada is looking across the fraser
river in langley bc we would love to see
your corner of the country so please
keep sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
this weekend have a great night
[Music]
you